ensuite on va passer au fond Emmanuel
Macron une nouvelle fois Hue et ce matin
par des manifestants devant le collège
de Ganges dans l'Hérault
comme vous voulez
lorsque le président arrive au collège
Louise-Michel le député la France
insoumise de la circonscription lui
offre un livre sur la résistance clin
d'oeil appuyé aux manifestants réunis
tout près je passe qui vous attend
à parler je pense qu'ils sont pas parler
des casseroles c'est pour faire la
cuisine monsieur
c'est pas l'isolement et donc le
président de la République c'est normal
qu'il aille au contact de français et je
pense qu'il s'attendait est-ce que ce
soit difficile mais c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il y va
avancer le pays vous pensez pas que ça
aggrave non
regardez comment sont les gens les gens
certains sont d'accord de pas d'accord
quand on entend notre président de la
République on a l'impression qu'il a
passé trois mois enfermé dans son Falcon
mais qu'il a toujours pas compris ce qui
se passait dans la rue qu'il a toujours
pas compris que depuis trois mois il y a
des millions de personnes qui ont
manifesté et qu'on a battu tous les
records de manifestations depuis
l'après-guerre
faire un président chahuter un président
planqué
on est bien là dans nos ministères ou
dans les bâtiments publics du
gouvernement de l'exécutif mais enfin
l'important c'est aussi d'aller sur le
terrain à la rencontre des Français et
ben voilà madame elle est pas contente
mais non peut-être une image un peu
voilà mais elle le dit avec le sourire
c'est déjà plus sympa je vais pas
démissionner je vous rassure je vous
rassure ça n'arrivera pas faudra
attendre 2027 mais c'est pas grave je
préfère un président qui est face à des
français parfois en colère et c'est une
réalité dans notre pays à des
déplacements potenkins on vous met en
face de vous des personnes qui sont
forcément ravies et heureuse c'est pas
courageux d'aller voir les électeurs ce
qui courageux c'est de prendre des
bonnes décisions pour le pays y compris
quand elles vont contre son idéologie y
compris quand elles vont contre les
intérêts de ceux qui l'ont porté au
pouvoir donc ce serait courageux pour
Monsieur Macron c'est que une fois dans
sa vie ils disent je me suis trompé non
seulement pas qu'il le disent qu'il le
pense et qu'il le fasse
[Musique]
les élections il s'exprime aussi
parler
l'Inter syndical qui était en début
d'après-midi dans le quartier de la
Défense près de Paris ils ont notamment
envahi le bâtiment de ronext la
principale place boursière de la zone
euro et un symbole surtout du CAC 40 il
a dit que c'est pas les casseroles qui
gouvernent mais c'est c'est arrêté la
provocation donc non c'est pas fini il y
a un 1er mai qu'on veut massif
pourquoi nous sommes ici parce que c'est
le symbole du CAC 40 il y a une affiche
le CAC 40 à la caisse pour payer nos
retraites nous n'en pouvons plus de vos
mots de vous à locutions à non plus
finir avec votre langage pompeux qui
coupe une partie de la population des
informations directes ce que vous avez
fait madame la Première ministre c'est
du mépris social merci donc vous aurez
compris que l'expression est libre
et qu'on vous écoute moi on essaie on
essaie de le faire pour réaliser ce défi
il faut être très fort en BMX et ne pas
avoir le vertige c'est sur une
montgolfière à plus de 600 mètres de
hauteur que Chris Kalle a effectué ses
acrobaties
cela fait 30 secondes que la méga fusée
a décollé déjà plusieurs moteurs
connaissent des explosions 5 sont à
l'arrêt mais le mastodonte de 120 mètres
de haut continue de s'arracher vers le
ciel j'ai pas la formation je vais
activer le son pour voir
et là on a l'impression quand même que
il s'est peut-être produit quelque chose
qui n'était pas prévu
au moment où le vaisseau Starship doit
se séparer du lanceur la fusée décroche
c'est l'explosion c'est au moment de la
séparation entre le premier et le
deuxième étage qui ne s'est pas fait et
ce qui voudrait dire que le deuxième
étage à ce moment-là lui s'est allumé
évidemment on s'allumant avec le contact
du premier bon ben ça a déclenché cette
éclipse de soleil totale elle était
visible notamment du nord-ouest de
l'Australie dont nous parvient cette
vidéo la lune s'est glissée devant le
soleil 58 secondes de pénombre et d'un
spectacle exceptionnel